σε ότι δήποτε μας ενοχλ μας προσβάλλει και στο τέλος της ημέρας θα αποδείξουμε με
τη δουλει μας ότι θα γίνει και πρέπει να με δίκαιος και λικρινής η διαδικασία
ξεκλείδωσε καιγια το θέμα του κυπέδου με την πολή έντον είν ενέργεια και ιδιάθεση την
οποία έβαλε μας ζίμας και πολλές ώρες και αμετρίτς ώρες ουπουργός μεταφορών ο κύριος βαφιάτης
και εξεπαγγέλματος είχε τις τεχνικές γνώσεις να βοηθήσει και να βρει διάφορες λύσεις και διάφορες
επιλογές ήταν ο άνθρωπος οποίος με την ιρεμία του αλλά και με τη διάθεση του
μας έδι και μας εκείνο το εστρατοκίνητρο να συνεχίσουμε στη διαδικασία θα επανέλθω στις συνέχεια
για τον γυρό πάςκετπαμε λίγο στατουν βάσκι τις την κύπρου ναι τα τελευταία χρόνια φαίνεται
τον πας και είναι φτωχός συγγνείς σε κάποια πράγματα ο κόσμως γιατί δεν το αγκαλιζητος
θα πω ότι η κύπρος γαγια να δούμε προς έχει ίνα μεγάλον πασκετσικώ κοινό αυτό
είναι εδομένο για γονός δηλαδή ο κύπριος σας ταξιδεψει θα πανα διάρφα ένα θα διολιπιακό
θα ενιπανα θει να εκν θα πάειστόφα είναι αλφορ θα πάει σε μεγαλές δι οργανώσεις
θα κάτσι στην τηλιώραση να δει την ευρολήγκα θα σχοληθεί ασχολείτει με τον πάσκ εμπιε
αλλά να πάει το σάβατος το κήπεναεδώ κμεθάθηκε ατημάγια αυτό είναι κάτι το οποίο βλέπουμε
και εμείς δεν θα πω ότι δεν έχουν κινή βήματα βιβαίος έχου γίνει πάρα πολλά
βήματα μπροστά και βλέπουμε και οικογαέείναιες βλέπουμε και κόσμο να επηγαίνει στα γύπεδα ιδιυρκά ιδιαίτερα
όταν φτάνουμε προς το τέλος δηλαδήείτες στο κυπελλονιτες στελικούς προταθήματος αλλά δεν υπάρχει εκείνον το
έντων στιχίον τοοποίον ι παλαιότερη και πριν από τη γενιά ντηδική μας θυμούνται που γέμιζαν
τα γύπεδα τα κλειστά τότηταν και ανοικτά στα τσιμέθα στις παραδοσιακές γειτονιές εόθ θυμ όταν
έπαιση τεν κεραυνός